Barbie is wreaking havoc on the
podiatrist Community a new Tick-Tock
trend has fans recreating the film scene
in which Barbie steps out of her pink
high heels only for her feet to remain
in the same arched shape as those of her
doll inspiration Dr Jody r showenhouse a
podiatrist at the foot ankle and leg
vein center told the New York Post if
attempting the pose and stride over long
periods there are some risks involved
the ankle is unstable which can lead to
ligament sprains and injuries commonly
seen with high heel use the good news is
that simply participating in the
challenge won't leave any lingering
effects Dr schoenhaus went on to say
that if someone only strikes the pose a
time or two it won't do any serious
damage that said walking around like
Barbie too much can lead to ligament
sprains as well as muscle and spine
problems she explained to walk on your
toes without heels isn't sustainable in
fact the reality in the movie is that
Barbie actually has flat feet along with
30 percent of the population